Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the chapter of patience of authored
by
the narration finishing up the
narration or the meanings of the
narration that we had begun yesterday
morning. The narration as stated by
[Silence]
Bkari
on the authority of Abi who narrates
that the messenger of Allah
said whomever Allah desires good for he
will afflict afflict with
difficult difficulty afflict with
hardship. Hardship that will not
break him but rather hardship that will
force him to grow to rise to the
occasion. This is to
make him better and more eligible for
higher reward in the hereafter and more
useful in the life of this dunya but
also as an expeation of his sins and a
raising of his levels as the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam has
mentioned in other narrations
and that is that this is the
way of the
prophets and messengers. They are
afflicted by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
They are patient. They are designated
enemies to overcome. They are able by
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to overcome
these enemies and they are able to grow.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us that
he is truly successful. The one who has
managed to purify and grow and nourish
and expand his soul.
What is this
process of tes
and nefes
this process of growing and purifying
the soul it is with two main
ingredients. Number one, revelation,
knowledge, revelation, the words of
Allah, the wisdom, the understanding of
how and why
and what to expect these things occur
and what is expected of a person upon
each occurrence. Number two,
difficulties to overcome. When you have
these two elements together and they are
often mentioned in the Quran, water and
fire are often mentioned together in the
Quran. Water
is
synonymous in its analogy to the Quran
and fire is synonymous in its analogy to
difficulties and trials and
tribulations.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions both
together throughout the Quran in
multiple places. And so when a person
learns, receives revelation or learns
revelation and then they experience and
have to overcome.
This is the process that purifies the
soul, expands the soul, makes the soul
better and makes the person better for
the rest of humanity. As we heard
yesterday in the statement of the
prophet sallall.aii
That people are precious metals
just gold and silver. Meaning each
one has that which they were created
for. Each one has a potential. Each one
has been created exactly for
a particular
field or a particular path or level
of life that they are to fulfill. Not
everyone is going to be you know made
out of gold. We need silver. We need
bronze. We need other types of metal.
And not everyone is going to be made out
of silver because we need gold etc. And
so
these things may be
one may be superior to the other in raw
material
but the final product is far more than
what the raw material merely is. And
this takes us back to the argument of
aan the argument of aan.
I'm better than he is. You created me
from fire and he from clay. If we were
to for argument's sake say that sure
fire is superior to clay and raw
material. That doesn't mean that
everyone who is of fire is better than
every individual who is of clay. Even if
that were true, that would be like
saying everything made out of gold is
better than every item made out of
silver. Incorrect.
Right? This is something that has much
to do with
the context, much to do with what it is
relative to. There are pieces of jewelry
in the jewelry store made out of silver
which are far superior to many pieces of
jewelry made out of gold. That's not
always the case. That's not most usually
the case. But that is the difference
between the final product and the raw
material. Why is this important? Because
just as every raw material needs a
jeweler to give it attention in order to
bring out its full potential, likewise
the human being needs the attention and
care of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That comes by way of knowledge. that
comes by way of difficulty and
challenges to overcome that shape the
person into the final thing that they
will be resurrected before Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala as which as we
will come to see is only had by way of
difficulty
Judah and
alhamdulillah.